let's make pork tocino now eat this with
garlic rice and egg it's over okay I'll
be using pork belly but you can also use
shoulder or anything you want now we're
gonna score it
sugar
garlic soy sauce vinegar pineapple juice
and some red food color salt black
pepper now put in the meat I'm gonna
give that a good mix now we're gonna
marinate this for two to three days okay
it's been three days and the tosino is
ready to be cooked since there's a lot
of sugar in this dish we're just gonna
cook it in low medium heat you don't
want to burn the sugar
Now isn't that beautiful this is a
traditional Filipino classic okay we
love it sweet but if you don't like it
as sweet just reduce the sugar do
whatever you want